thank you for talking to me about this i
just wanted to dance the entire time i
watched this movie
and i'm curious what it's like to create
such a collection of different songs
from each other each one of these
characters gets their own song their own
moment to shine it also fits their
personality what are the challenges of
developing a soundtrack like that
um the challenge is the complexity of
bringing 12 major characters
all to the screen and that was the
challenge we set up for ourselves at the
beginning
we said we want to talk about family
and we want to present an
intergenerational family all under one
roof and usually when you say that then
you chip away at the family until you
find your hero and the hero goes on a
quest moana had eight brothers when i
got hired from moana he does not have
eight brothers anymore because moana had
more important stuff to do um and so
hanging on to that um the the really
exciting challenge um was finding the
drama and the conflict of the movie
itself within the relationships between
those characters and so my job as the
composer is to amplify these characters
their gifts and um and their musical
version of self-expression and and the
way we did it
is actually a sleight of hand because
you said every person gets their song
but they super don't i have to write
these i got to write these incredible
ensemble songs wherein everyone gets
their moment and so you know i remember
pitching we don't talk about bruno
because every family has the stuff
you're allowed to talk about at the
dinner table and the stuff that you're
going to talk about but not in front of
mom or not in front of abuela like not
now and we don't talk about bruno let's
proceed to talk about bruno
that as an ensemble number provided an
incredible opportunity to hear from
dolores to hear from camilo we don't
have time to hear their songs but we
really get a strong sense of who dolores
is in those 12 bars she has and so that
was it was really exciting finding the
mix between solo numbers and group
numbers and letting every family member
shine uh within that kaleidoscope
all of the songs in this are great but
the one that has really stuck with me
since seeing the film as surface
pressure louisa's song
why was that the perfect song and the
perfect sound for that character um
surface pressure is my love letter slash
apology to older siblings everywhere um
and i think that
i i am a baby brother i have a sister
who was six years older i know she had
responsibilities that i did not have i
know she had burdens i did not have um
and
um and really writing honestly about
that lyrics like give it to your sister
your sister is older give her all the
heavy things you can't shoulder that
never mind i'll do it
um that's something that i really wanted
to write to because something i also
know that's true about my sister in
particular may be true of people in your
family that you know is that the tougher
and exterior they present actually the
more vulnerable and sensitive they are
on the inside and
my sister's the easiest crier um if i
cry at the end of a movie my sister
cries at the trailer for the movie um
she's actually got the softest
underbelly which is why the exterior is
so tough uh and so i knew writing that i
would find that kind of turn in it
because that's something i didn't really
learn about my sister until we were
grown-ups together and so much of the
movie is about that of seeing your
family members more fully as you grow
and as you evolve and as you change
you've gotten to work with one of your
musical heroes on the music for the
little mermaid
what did you learn from working and
collaborating with someone like alan
menken who's both a disney legend and a
songwriting legend yeah alan is the
reason i'm in this business i'm here
because little mermaid blew my mind and
um howard ashman and alan menken shaped
my childhood and so it took us a while
to get started because i think we were
both
um
nervous to go first
to present lyrics or to present music
what i learned
alan is maybe our greatest melodist
since richard rogers he his doodles are
better than any melody i will write in
my life and um and leaning into that and
also but what he loves is to bounce off
of something and so as soon as i started
writing lyrics
it wrote really fast because he is he's
so quick in terms of once he's got his
head around the style
a song is he's got it and he's got 50
melodies uh to pick and choose from um
and and so you know again it's like
anything else you talk and you talk
until the moment is right and you
understand the musical moment you're
dramatizing um and then it's a matter of
keeping up with alan menken because he's
fast
you've done
so many disney projects now and as
someone who's really sort of firmly
entrenched as part of the disney family
at this point
if you could create a song for any
existing character from any of the
previous disney projects whether it
would be for a film or a theme park ride
or
just anything is there a character that
you would just like love to write their
own song for
oh man i mean i so much of my work on
little mermaid was that wish fulfillment
um
i actually didn't write any new songs
for sebastian the crab i think because i
love his songs so much i was like i
can't no not me i can't do it um i did
get to write for some of the other
characters uh in that movie
every song you love in little mermaid is
still in little mermaid we just found
some new moments uh to musicalize um but
that's really tricky i can tell you one
of the ones that i didn't watch so much
growing up that my kid loves is sword in
the stone um
there's something so incredible about
when that wolf first shows up to menace
wart i saw my kid get really scared for
the first time and then immediately the
wolf like falls down a cliff and like
falls on his face and the laugh my kid
let out when that happened was so
delicious it was like this such a lesson
in like tension and release and relief
um so there's probably something fun in
sort of the stone to to be mined i don't
know i'm spitballing
well i appreciate it i tremendously love
this and i'm waiting for like the dance
class with this music because
thank you so much for talking to me
about it thank you it's my pleasure